this morning more than 50 million people
in the northeastern US are under a heat
advisory or warning the National Weather
Service says it will feel as hot as 105
degrees in some areas from Washington to
Boston at least 20 schools in Ohio are
closed today because of those high
temperatures CBS is running Saturday
co-host Michelle Miller is in Queens New
York where the heat led to a rule change
at the US Open Michelle good morning
good morning it was so hot out here
yesterday the US tennis officials
allowed male players to take 10-minute
breaks after their third set and as day
three of the US Open begins these
oppressive temperatures will continue to
change the state of play don't do much
being back to nice various parts of the
body two-time US Open champion Novak
Djokovic did all that he could to keep
cool in New York City scorching heat it
felt like a hundred and five degrees on
the court at one point he called his
cardiologist to check his health and
even had a bucket nearby in case he got
sick I definitely wasn't feeling feeling
great for most of the three sets
Djokovic won his match but at least six
other players quit before finishing many
citing heat related issues a fan even
fainted during another match prompting
officials to temporarily suspend play it
was much the same in Manhattan it's
really humid I must say it's crazy the
heat is having a ripple effect on
schools across multiple states in the
Cleveland Ohio area at least 18 schools
are closed today classes in Philadelphia
ended early Tuesday and are slated to be
cut short again today classes in
Connecticut and Massachusetts also
shorten sessions not all parents agreed
with the adjustments even make it a full
day fix the AC unit so don't have them
coming at all in Rhode Island a state
senator is proposing a bill calling for
school to begin after Labor Day to try
and avoid summer ending Scorchers we
don't want him standing outside and
waiting for the school bus an extreme
cold weather why should we have
understanding
school buses in hot weather and back
here at the US Open tennis officials
tell us that those heat related break
rules will remain in effect today
because they could extend all the way
through the weekend
it will not cool down before Friday and
one more thing Gail by the look of it
the players out here are not loving this
heat if you're sitting in the stands
you're not loving it either I don't know
how they do it on the court because it's
tough in the stands thanks Michelle it's
the stickiness yeah I mind the heat it's
just so darn sticky